Italy's Prime Minister Matteo Renzi says
he's resigning after the crushing defeat
of a referendum the headline in one
Italian newspaper reads no triumphs
Renzi leaves the boat against political
reform maybe another sign of rising
anti-establishment sentiment in Europe
Seth Doane is outside the Prime
Minister's residence in Rome South good
morning good morning this was a stunning
loss for Matteo Renzi and just the
latest in a string of populist upsets
but the prime minister said the people
had spoken and he would turn in his
resignation to Italy's president today
Italian Prime Minister Matteo Renzi
wanted voters to choose see reforms he
argued would decrease bureaucracy his
case wasn't convincing enough I have
lost he said and I say it out loud
although with a lump in my throat frenzy
personalized this constitutional
referendum early on which Charlie Rose
asked him about on 60 minutes it's
become a vote about you and that's not
good yes this is was my mistake in the
first days of electoral campaign I
understand a mistake the opposition
celebrated the news one of the loudest
no voices was the populists [ __ ] west
LA or five stars movement this vote here
in Italy continues this
anti-establishment mood we've seen in
the US and elsewhere here in Europe yes
we asked louis university professor pier
paolo benigno about this shock to the
system in general uncertainty is
something that the market doesn't like
and here there are lots of degree of
uncertainty
and this crisis comes at a time of high
unemployment and significant debt issues
here in Italy across Europe other
anti-establishment parties are watching
this vote with elections coming up in
France and then down the road in Germany
Nora huge implications Seth Doane in
Rome thank you so much